You know, we're tightening up their formation accelerating. Now they're above 10000 feet. You can
accelerate above 253100 knots. Mhmm. And so they're accelerating
probably 3.50 closing in the formation, and then the leads
see something go by his aircraft. And what he described was a dark gray or
black cued inside of a instead of a clear sphere. At this point, we've been
seeing and talking about them enough where he's just like, I don't see why those
same thing. We all knew what he was talking about. There is no real mechanism
to report this, both from a a military perspective as well as
a commercial perspective. And it happened multiple ones. Right? There were multiple
sightings of the similar type of variety from different pilots? Yep.
Okay. Today, we'll be talking about the most advanced and subjects imagine.
From fighter jet technology to planetary orbits to the theory of
relativity. The best way to learn about these fascinating subjects
doesn't cost 1000 of dollars or take years years of
schooling. It's actually free and easy. Brilliant is a great way to
learn the fundamentals of engineering data science, analysis,
probability statistics, and everyday technology. Plus, you can
even take an in-depth course about quantum mechanics from our good friend
Sabina Hossen elder. It's a fresh and new perspective on learning advanced
topics. Take a quick quiz when you first sign in and you'll be matched with
content that fits your skill level and interest. Whether you're a
complete noob or you're ready to write programs for a quantum
computer. Brilliant's guidelines let you explore concepts at your
own pace. If you get stuck, there are helpful hints and step by step
solutions to get you back on track. Science and analysis skills are
only getting more in demand, which is why I love their new data analysis
fun mentals course. It gives you a step by step approach to learning everything you
need to know to get started in this exciting field. Within a few quick lessons,
you'll get to analyze real data and draw conclusions from it. the kind of analysis
that forms the backbone for a lot of my research and even my
content to try everything brilliant has to offer for free for a
full 30 days, visit brilliant.org/doctorbrian
Keating. That's brilliant.org/dr briankeatiandg,
or just click on the link in the description. The first 200 of you will
get 20% off of Brilliant's annual premium
subscription. Any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from magic.
yours truly. Doctor Brian Keating alive on
YouTube at least with with my new friend. Ryan
Graves. Lieutenant Ryan Graves. Former lieutenant, you're no longer
serving in the active duty. You're here in San Diego, and I wanted to
let you yourself to the to the into the impossible family. You're
a fan favorite. We want to have you on for a long time, and thanks
to my buddy, Ariel. We were able to get you so welcome. Thanks for having
me here. Way introduction. My name is Ryan Graves. I joined the
navy out of college. I went to school in Central
Massachusetts. I joined the navy. While in training, I actually met Ari here,
and we can talk more about that in a little bit. I believe you invited
me on here today because I've come somewhat of a public spokesperson on the the
issue of UAP now because we were seeing these objects flying
around. And so so, yeah, that's that's a start. You know? I've
engaged this topic a few organizations when you talk about that a bit later, so
I'm still engaged in the topic. Yeah. Happy happy to be here and try to
answer any questions I can. Yeah. I just to recapitulate my
friend Ariel. Ariel, can you give your background and do your
second appearance on the InterDigital Podcasts after meeting with
Fazard Lead for his book, The Art of Clear Thinking of Ben Labor.
Tell us about yourself. Grew up in New Jersey. Join the navy shortly
after college and went through flight training with Ryan and Meridian, then we
kinda split paths. I went on West Coast. I think you went east, and
then I ended up at the at a squadron on the East
Coast, and we're on the same carrier. So and we did a lot of our
workups and training together and then deployed
Both of us made about half the deployment, and then we rotate it out. What
got you into aviation? Why did you wanna do that? You went to Worcester Polytech,
you're an engineer. Braniac nerd probably growing up as
a kid. What made you wanna fly high performance fighter jets except for the fact
that it's every little boy's because it's a high performance fighter jet.
So, you know, it wasn't something I I did dream about as a child.
It wasn't something I was exposed to. I didn't have any, you know, pilots or
crew in in my family. You know, I grew up in a very
rural small town, so it wasn't something I was initially exposed to on a regular
basis externally as well. But, you know, I've always been very
interested in technology and all the things that come with it, advancement,
new understanding, scientific discovery, And for me, jet
aircraft, at least that that is almost was a personification of that, you
know, cutting edge technology. That's where so much effort was put
into place, and that was a place where I could go. And I could take
in all those experiences, all that technology, you know, all that operational
capability, right, and just kinda test myself not only intellectually, but
as part of a team as, you know, someone that has to interact with his
hands as well as his mind, potentially. So we just need, like, a great challenge.
I didn't know where it would end. I had, you know, perhaps some dreams of
being able to offshoot NASA or do the after not think didn't
have that opportunity. But I just saw that that would hopefully
give me enough experience to be able to go out and do something fascinating the
world after that. Uh-huh. What about you? I don't think I ever
really understood how you got tied up and left
Princeton and went into went in to serve your country. But what what was it?
What was it about the navy in particular? I mean, David Sperkel proved to me
I was not gonna become a an astrophysicist
Great teacher, but no. I I realized I wasn't great at the theoretical.
I kinda maxed out at quantum physics and decided afterwards
to to go into the navy when I had always been fascinated with the
Apollo program, and I had dreams
of eventually becoming a NASA astronaut. also been kinda pan out that
way. To include the the more I thought about space and not, you know, topic
for another day, but it takes a huge toll on the human body. And I
like being physical on earth and, like, eating good food and
drinking good wine, and I wanna climb Paul Mountain. So You're doing the dinner,
by the way, since tonight in my house. Well, it's a great girl to have
here. So, Ryan, what brings you to San Diego? You were you're one of the
cofounders of a very important organization. So people know I'm on I'm a
pilot, but not like these American heroes, real life American heroes. I fly a little,
you know, sustenance around. But I'm very interested in aviation. We're gonna geek out. We're
gonna nerd out on astronomy. physics, and
aviation. Fair warning. We're gonna throw in some AI and maybe some
aliens. We'll see about that. What brings you to San Diego, Ryan? It's so great
to have you. Yeah. So I I came into San Diego this week because the
American Institute of aeronautics and astronautics for the AIAA as
I'll refer to it. I chair a committee there called the UAP or unidentified
anomalous phenomenon integration and outreach committee. It's a it's a full
committee within the AI double a. forwarded to that
status within the Institute. And that is an integration committee. Essentially,
our charge is to be able to bring together experts within that committee that have
a, you know, a wide variety of capabilities and be able to interface
both in our in our technical activities there within the sub committee, but also to
reach out across all the what they call technical committees
that comprise majority of the AI double a and be able to
integrate those technical expertise spin up teams with particular
capabilities or expertise as needed. And so that
organization is having their aviation 2023 conference, which
is largest professional conference for everything in the air
for space. And these are, you know, engineers from NASA from the startup community.
from, you know, your large defense corporations. And there's a
bunch of papers that are presented there. And as a committee, we participate in that,
and we had a paper presented on the UAP topic during this
conference, 4 of them were in person. I present one of those papers. It was
on potential reporting mechanisms for UAP. with the existing
aviation safety frameworks, and then we had 4 more in the virtual session as well.
So that's what brought me, and we just finished that up here. Today's Friday. So
really happy I could finish it up with you. And I should also mention your
host of the Merge podcast, which I very much enjoy. It's got -- Much higher
production values than we're sporting down here at the nor just a public
university, Renata. You you private citizens out there. So
I think one of the things that's most interesting to me Yes. As an
aviation geek, as an aviation nerd, is if you were to say to
an average individual or maybe commercial pilot a lot of commercial pilots listen to
this, podcasts. I'm sure they listen to yours, and they were to see
something. What what is your first step? I mean, what what do people do? And
and it could be I'm aiming on the ground witnessing some sort of phenomena. But
in particular, in the air, just take it from that perspective. I'm flying along the
coast of California, not far from warning area off the coast of
Catalina. I see something. What do I do? Well, you do what you should always
do as a pilot, which is aviate, navigate, and communicate. You shouldn't necessarily
let self be distracted by what you're seeing. At this point in the game, right,
you don't know what this object is. It's probably more likely just a balloon or
a u UAV or something of that nature. And so
the idea here is if you see something that's unidentified that you should now, you
know, go deviate from your course to go inspect or something like that. Right? So
that's not what's being communicated here. You should be a professional pilot if
you do observe it, and you believe it could be a threat to other air
traffic the proper procedure would be to reach out to your air traffic controller
and see if that traffic is known. And if not, you'd like to give them
a position where it is so they can weren't other traffic about it. One
thing I've been hearing from talk with commercial pilots is that it's essentially what's
been happening right now is that they'll see something either at their altitude or in
the vicinity of their altitude. Other aircraft are seeing it as well, and they're calling
up the ATC. And they're all kind of confirming it that it's there, but they
don't know what it is, and they can visually see it. there's nothing else really
to do at that point. So that's part of the problem I've been trying
to resolve is that there is no real mechanism to report this
both from a a military perspective as well as a commercial perspective.
On the military perspective, at this point to see, we don't really have the ability
to report unknown objects in any way that would have got resolved It was simply
we had the Navy Aviation Safety Keating mechanisms, and
those are, you know, not an investigatory type of system.
ASAP report. Yeah. So, you know, it's data collection after the fact. So there
really was nothing. And if those represented, you know, potentially after serial
platforms, that was ultimately my fear at the time was that these could have potentially
been some type of platform just spying on us, and that's something I've been
communicating a bit on. I'm getting off track here. So I'll jump
back. On the commercial side, what what should the pilots do? Right now, in the
far in the far, the federal aviation regulations -- Publicism.
-- it instructs aircrew, they would like to
report one of these. They don't require it in any way. They
essentially suggest that the the aircrew or the witness could go
report that to any number of UFL Keating centers that
are out in the general public none of which are well funded or, you know,
consistent with each other. And so more or less information just gets scattered out. And
so that's one of the issues that I'm working to resolve from a procedural point
with the AI double a to be able to make those recommendations. Also, with the
other organization, I started American for, say, aerospace where we can provide
general education and and education on Capitol Hill to be able to push for
those procedures, be able to push for that, you know, potentially mandatory reporting
so that pilots don't feel like they can't can't bring that information forward
to HTC in the old. Yeah. Is it I mean, there's a stigma in aviation.
You know, you do something. There's a pilot deviation, the air traffic controls. Here's a
phone number to call. You know, what you're supposed to write down right after you
had some incident. You know, is there a sense that, like, pilots are not reporting
because they're gonna get some list where, you know, Will Will Smith's gonna come up
and do some clicking to them or or that the FAA is gonna pull their
ticket. They can't fly anymore on the commercial side. There's some concerns about I don't
think it's anything, you know, men in black and nefarious, but guys just generally don't
wanna be associated with it. They don't want it to answer for it. They'd rather
keep their head down. And, you know, I say that from the context of the
people that have been calling me for the past, you know, 8 months or more.
Yeah. That's what they're reporting. And when they first reached out to me, know, some
of the stories we're guiding you even wanna call it out to HTC -- Right.
-- because they didn't want their calls associated with that report, essentially. So that's
where the state of affairs was. course, it's not evenly spread, but I hear that's
better now. People are calling it out more, but it was disappointing to see that
during the NASA independent study team public meeting, that
FAA representative communicate they wasn't even aware of any procedures for pilots
to report on. Yes. That's, like, the most sports games. Right? yeah, they seem
to be good at, you know, kinda punishing pilots and and if the FAA is
out there, please do not, you know, pull my ticket. Ariel, we we talked
over at lunch not too long ago about, you know, events, things you saw when
you were in combat or in training, you're flying a per horn and also
but were you both single seat pilots? Was it about single seat aircraft, or were
do you guys double? I was single seat. Ryan flew Two seaters you
told me once, and maybe you could tell the story, but you're encounter with a
UAP at the time. I can't can you actually,
actually? No. No. I I In both cases, it was it was observable for
me. So I I didn't have any anything too crazy. I
one time in the whiskey area is off the coast of Virginia, we did
pick up a lot of little, like, scatter and 1 I was
able to to lock on to this, and it ended up I did a right
to right with a balloon. there was another time in the Persian Gulf, and this
was more worrisome because I've come in off the carrier. I I pick up a
a contact going real slow. not getting called out from
from air traffic at the boat, lock him up. I
have a 9 x missile, which all has another sensor on it, and that
actually gets tone, which tells me there's something there, end up doing
a right to right with a Iranian drone. Yeah. The way to write me
is you're you're Keating off. So -- Basically, we're just kinda flew right
by. Yeah. So it was an Iranian drone that was orbiting near the near the
carrier. You know, dangerous from a standpoint of one we should be
aware that it's there, which the boat may have been. It was just more
warning the pilots. Hey. You know? And I, you know, I remember reading
and Donald Rumsfeld's biography, you know, of of all places that, you know, he
said once that if president Bush wanted to kill somebody, it
took about 17 different phone calls and, you know, telegrams
and encrypted, you know, data sources before that person would meet
his untimely end. Oh, his or her. We should be inclusive.
lot of lot of, you know, worrisome women out there. Right?
What what about that? If you saw this, you identify it as as
some threat from a from a hostile nation? Do you have authorization?
You have tone? You know? I mean, you said that that means, by the way,
we should we should although you and I are aviation nerds or Ryan as
well. What is lock on? What kind of sensor technology are we talking
about? These are radar sensors and a flare? What what are they exactly? The radar
usually is the first sensor you're gonna use. That's kind of your broadest
that's gonna pick up the most. Everything else starts to to zero in. So in
that case, I was coming off the boat, and and we have to do checks
on our our system, so that's why I I use the 9 x. And that's
a sidewinder. -- a sidewinder missile. It's a heat's heat it it looks for
heat sources. You know, even at that point, my my aircraft safe. There's no way
for me to shoot this missile. Like, man, I have no intention to do that,
to broader on your question. we would have to have I mean, there are
rules of engagement that are very clear that dictate how you can employ
your weapon systems. And with it being a peacetime scenario,
unless that drone fired upon me or was looking to be a
threat to US forces. There's nothing I would really legally be able
to do. Mhmm. Then we're we're hamstrung pretty tightly with the ROE. But it
also allows you to keep keep yourself safe. But, you
know, unfortunately, we're not in in in hostilities at that man
or Fortunately, we're not in hostility. So -- I'm having no luck. Yeah. None of
the eastern seaboard. It's a little different. People don't quite understand, but we're not really
in a operational mode when we're operating
training. So we we I never almost carry live ordinance out there. That would be
a a big exception. So that would take, like, you said, probably 17 phone calls,
at least, something like that. that actually came an issue. Actually, 90911
was when they were looking to go get the other airplanes. We had a lot
of fighter jets on the East Coast, but, you know, we never never even thought
to to have them weaponized and armed. So, you know, you had fighter
pilots that were told that they might have to go after aircraft, and they're trying
to think through how they're gonna potentially take out a threat aircraft without
any weapon systems on board. So there's people asking in the
audience. By the way, you can ask questions in the live chat down below or
on Twitter. We need people on their contract. Currently, a 186
on YouTube and want more kinda tuning in through Twitter, I believe.
So you mentioned this whiskey air. What is that? What is the whiskey areas at
the, like, where we're gonna drink some on this Glenlivet that I got special made?
What is a whiskey area? What does that mean? and when it would take effect.
We we call it Whiskey on a map. You just see it as w w
stands for warning area. So warning area, 72,
I'm sure there's a 73 and a 71 somewhere. But So that's generally, this is
the -- You know, north to south, but, generally, the airspace is divvied up in
the blocks. And their warning area is essentially And I could be slightly wrong here,
so correct me if I'm wrong. But they're essentially warning inbound
international traffic is what that's for. So as military
operators, we're out there playing because it's unused airspace. It's
not unique to us. Other people can directly transit it,
although they would get called out. That's that's essentially just where we
train. Yeah. So it it's a Moa off the water. So -- Moa's
-- -- operating area, which same thing. It it diverts IFR
instrument traffic, which is mostly commercial airliners, diverts you
around those areas that we can play. But legally speaking, a guy in
a Sesna flying VFR and go right through the middle of it. And it and
it happens and, you know, that we get called, hey, there's a, you know,
172 Transit the Moa 10000 feet, and -- Right. -- we have to
stop our stuff, which can be pretty expensive with $30,000 per
hour or 20 to 30,000 per hour. Sometimes you would use the I mean, you're
not gonna shoot on them, but you're gonna use them for training. Right? You're gonna
might lock and assess them or something like that. I'll just say your radar's almost
always out there paying stuff. So, like, do lock up commercial air traffic, stuff like
that. But there's no, like, effect that's occurring on the aircraft. And
even if we didn't specifically lock someone, that interview Keating out there and paying
them anyways, And so these are microwaves of centimeter wavelength radars, and
then you've got FLIR and and so forth. Did the missiles themselves have an
optical sensor? Are they pure heat seeking? They're pure infrared or Can you
see the missile i in any way in the cockpit display, other heads up, or
a regular display? Can you physically look out and see the sensor? What do you
see from its perspective? Do you see, an infrared image -- No. -- now. But
you can see where the center is looking. So, you know, information will be on,
like, my visor or whatever. So show essentially where it's looking. There's a mode
where I could basically walk that to my cursor, if you will, so that I
can, you know, select stuff. Because you have far away it is. And okay. Mhmm.
So there's an area out here in your Calibbean island called
restricted to Romeo 2519. You know, it was a site of the so
called the tiktok encounter. We we don't have commander Favor on.
I'd love to love to meet him someday and talk to him someday. but that
also occurred in our restricted area, not our military, which is not
necessarily purely military the way a warning area might be. but it is
used for, you know, purposes for training purposes. Obviously, they they had a carrier
or something out there. Right? I would I would suggest it. I think it is
actually just a warning area. Right? It's not a it's not a restricted space because
that term means not very specific. Maybe
The restricted is usually means you're operating some sort
of, like, weapons test is generally where it's a highly sensitive
area. So off the coast, that could be restricted
if there's naval gunfire or something. But other than -- I mean, the point I'm
trying to make is, you know, this was another area It's a special use.
Yeah. So, you know, I was talking recently with a with a colleague going to
Nunez, but he was in the military intelligence field. You're talking about, you
know, the the preponderance of events of anomalies that seem to
occur near military area 51 is a huge, you know, groom
lake. Edward's Air Force Base, these two areas you guys are talking about,
or we're talking about, is there anything, you know, to be said about that? Like,
from the perspective of aviation safety at least, like, just avoid
those areas, or could it be, as some suggest, you know, people are either
the there's technology from an would like to go to those areas too and get
a sneak peek at an F Eighteen. Right? We're in a 30th time. So what
do you make about it? Is there anything, you know, to this theory that of
course, things are gonna happen in strange ways. You know? Call me when it happens
over Times Square kind of reaction that I often get. Well, my first
go to here is probably observation bias involved. So we're
seeing them there because we have the sensors to actually be able to
see. Now with that, I also don't think you know, this issue
is going to be one particular thing at the stand for a while, and, you
know, we're gonna find that material platform. We're gonna find their own and things that
I need. We're gonna find trash. that's great, and that's helpful to our national security.
And we have systems in place to mitigate that, but there's a
category that, you know, we're ignoring essentially at that that
dataset. And that's that's what I find we need to work down. So I think
we're gonna have AppCRO platforms around those bases, so there's gonna probably be ticking,
you know, unexplained or or
unidentified objects around those bases maybe just because they're
adversarial platform, but I think there's an observation bias as well. And to your point
earlier, you know, you're talking about kind of the aging probability of of,
you know, a commercial pilot, military pilot, seeing these in what what that
can affect. It's such a small bubble that a commercial pilot can see.
So, you know, when you're talking about sightings from fighter jets, you know, you have
the potential to get highly correlated data across multiple sensors, you
know, different types as well as, you know, different geographical locations of the
data or how if you will, other sourcing. Ground based sensors or
eyewitness statements things of that nature, you don't have that luxury necessarily.
And so we would expect to have much better data around those
systems. And in the on the commercial side, there you know, the visibility
range where you could see a, you know, one to four meter object is pretty
small depending on the conditions. It's certainly within ten nautical miles. We'll just
use that number. And if you think about, you know, the volume inside
that 10 mile bubble or 2, you know, what you get
with an ACE radar. It's pretty easy to see why we get more sightings of
that. There's more overlaid. There's more data. Right? Yeah. I mean,
our radars are way better than what is an assessment cycle
for a 747. Yeah. Right. And for different purposes,
right, they're eliminating other aerial threats, potentially.
So we were talking earlier as well before we started the the podcast.
about, you know, this kind of notion that a lot of times we'll engage with
with people in the military or people that have claimed to be eyewitnesses.
people talk about, like, oh, the data belongs to us. You know? I've had unhappy
Loeb who's coming back to talk about this book, which is excellent book sure to
be a best seller, and Avi sent his best, I'm sure, from the Fiji Islands
where he's apparently found some anomalous wires. He's
found some mangon someone in a live chat correct me that he
found something today who's announced on his medium page, which
I get. He found some strange metallic composition. And we're gonna
nerd out about, like, potentialities of of what could be found. So first of all,
you've had some contact with Ivy about and as students on on
your podcast and and him as well. Where does this kind of interest take
you beyond the very, very important and critical, you
know, deadly serious literally implications of of just anything in
the airspace that's not monitored, not tracked, where there might be a discourage
meant to reporting or visceral reactions to reporting
bias and so forth. But where where else do your
interest lie -- Mhmm. -- with regards to these phenomena. Like, do you enter
ever entertain the fact that they could be not of this earth, or is
that interesting, but it's not, like, necessarily what drives
your involvement, and I'll ask Leslie to be that question. Sure. So, I mean, for
me personally, Yeah. I I I think, you know, I would be
lying. I think most people would be lying to say, like, that obviously, that possibility
is extremely you know, tantalizing. Right? Yeah. That's just human nature, I
think. And, you know, like you were talking about earlier, that's something I've actually tried
to fight against to just be as objective and that focuses as I can.
so that there's there's no bias that I'm pushing subconsciously, although, of course,
we all are, but I'm doing my best. So I try
to draw a firm line in my mind of what I have, you know, firsthand
experience or or data. Right? And, you know, of course, second here, data
from learning and things of that nature. And I like to, you know, step
past that line and kind of explore where those extrapolations go a bit. I think
it's fun to do, but I don't let that affect you know, things on the
other side of that line, the things that I know because that's you know, extrapolation
is fun. So I do I like it. It's fun stuff. Like, you know, I'm
a sci fi fan, so all this is very interesting to me. I'm interested in
cutting edge technology in in where we can, you know, do that. I wanna be
able to support that type of stuff. That's all very interesting to me. But I
leave that on the other side of the line so that we can focus on
what's pragmatic, which is data and being able to just bring
it in and talk about it without stigma because that's where we're at. very basic
still -- Mhmm. -- suddenly. Where where you are now? What's your what's
your interest in this beyond, say, the very critical
life saving potentiality. And I should say you're involved with
aviation and space to this day as well. So where where do your interest take
you in this in this domain? Still flat. And so,
clearly, you know, anything that's in the air is of interest in a threat,
potential threat. Right? Wanna keep me and my passengers as safe as possible.
But No. I think there's a, you know, there's the good science
means looking into Keating, you know, people in the 19 fifties
sixties were seeing sprites, lightning strikes that go up into outer
towards outer space. And and, you know, I'm not very smart on the astroph
the physics of of these. But so know, I'm sure I'm gonna say something wrong
here. But for a while, scientific community, the community at large kind of
played that off. And in the end, there that is a real phenomenon, and
eventually, I think it was in the eighties. I think the space shuttle astronauts
could actually confirm that this was happening. And then you start looking, and now we're
you know, that's a that's an aspect of our of our world and our system
that we don't understand and didn't know about, really, till till people
started observing and starting to look into it. So you know, and just pushing
the scientific envelope requires curiosity about anything that you
don't you can't you don't know or don't understand. Yeah. I mean, I always say,
you know, There's no one more than a physicist or an astronomer who would like
to make contact with something beyond this realm because I think
it would shortcut First of all, guarantee employment, you know, fall employment through
astrophysicists forever. Right? If we ramped up our budget when there's just the
Soviet Union, you know, 10% of the area of the landmass of
Earth, that, you know, quintupled our budget for years to come. How much
more so would it be for discovering alien technology? But that's a
risk. We have to guard against because I think there's a lot of propensity
to want to leave stuff, and there's even the memes about you know, I want
to believe I don't wanna believe in gravity. You know? I've got evidence of gravity.
We can we can do experiments. We can replicate stuff. And I think, you know,
sometimes we we do have to guard upon it. And I think there
might be a little bit of a stigma Ryan that you could speak to that,
you know, when people let's say you report something, there's almost a
supposition on the on the part of the person who's hearing that report that,
oh, well, he wants to believe that. Does that enter into it where there is
this confirmation bias? Or is it like, hell no. I was this could kill this
could blow up my plane or this could be an enemy of the United States,
and I'm a patriot. I signed up to defend my country. Now what level do
you react negatively? So I said, oh, of course, he just wants to believe in
this things in science fiction. Like, we all do. But he's using, you know, the
fact that he's seen things or or witnessed things, you know, to bolster that. How
do you guard against because that it's a common claim that people make. Right? I
mean, no. Frankly, I haven't heard people claim that. But if if
they are, so be it. But you know, for me, I
tried to keep myself on the the line of what I've observed and what I've
directly talked to my colleagues and what they've seen. The other day, I'm just doing
my best to report on that and to improve the the aerospace safety around
it. Right? And so that's where my all my effort is. So if you wanna
look at my track record to justify my behavior, then they're
gonna see nothing but me focusing on aviation safety on this topic because
For me, that's the most pragmatic way that I can reach back and, you know,
be able to help the people that I used to fly with. Mhmm. Truly, that's
really where all this started. Do you mind if I ask you a semi personal
question that would be you don't you don't have to answer it. We could delete
it later. But, I mean, it it seems like this is very altruistic. Right? So
how are you gonna you know, do you have a family now? Right? I mean,
how is this gonna translate? I mean, everyone needs to provide for the material safety
of the family and security. I'm just curious. Like, you don't have to answer if
you don't want to, but, like, is there any way that that this can be
remunerated, you know, in some fashion or another? It seems very altruistic in other
words. And and Yeah. I don't think -- You've already done enough for your country
that, you know, that's one wouldn't say, oh, now it's your time to give back.
I mean, it's kinda you shouldn't be doing it for free is what I'm saying.
Well, you know, I think that what's most important in this conversation
is Keating up a self sustaining industry, if you will, around this.
Right? So I don't like the traditional pack that phone quote the UFO
community has on this where if anyone makes a dollar, then they're Keating
into that nature. I think we need to bring into this conversation
so that we can run experimentalist. We can build sensors. We can influence on
capital, though. We can do all the things that every other industry she does. So
I don't like that general logic because it relegates this conversation to the
hobby, and there is real work to be done. you know, I hope that generates
some income from the podcast, but I'm not, you know, not making any. What
about in terms of, like go ahead. you wanna speak
about other efforts that you're undergoing on that front? We could talk a little
bit more about that in the future a little bit later on. So one of
the well, I let's just do it now, I suppose. So there's a number of
things I'm doing. There's Americans for safe aerospace. That's a nonprofit.
And, you know, ideally, that would generate small amount of income for me. But
primarily, all the money there is more user pulling and research and things
of that nature. Mhmm. For the AI double a, that's a complete volunteer
organization. So I have nothing there. And
I think you understand the podcast game and how lucrative that can be. Oh, yeah.
That's I paid for the aluminum replicate the James Web space
only. But what I would like to do what I would like to do with
marriage with the podcast is take that conversation and develop it with the
help of the listener. be able to take the ideas we're getting, take
the the expertise that we've brought to the table, and raise
money around that and say, hey. Here are some ideas we've identified them, and can
we now support that ecosystem either by, you know, providing, potentially,
grants for experiments or or money to fund new
sensor technology, things of that nature. So I wanna be able to grow and
expand this ecosystem. I think that's really the way to do it.
Yeah. Yeah. That's that that was excellent. And it's kind of the model Avi Loeb
is used. I mean, with with more kind of contacts by use of the
he he employs h bomb, you know, drops Harvard on people. And all of a
sudden, billionaire show up at his doorstep as he's told me in his pie. So
he's right now in a cruise in the south seas near Fiji, excavating
where the first interstellar meteorite, the first one that they have documented.
There's been probably millions of them over in cosmic history. So this
leader of the spectrometer company, Bruckner Spectrum, dropped
a couple mill and said, let's go out there. So but the citizen science model
you actually have way more people that are interested in aviation and fly and so
forth. Everyone who's on a commercial plane can get be a witness. Right? So is
that kind of the the effort as well. Citizens, science, or citizen.
I don't know what you'd call it. But, yeah, is there a way to incorporate
the general public? I mean, you could speak to the audience, What can they do
to a system? Especially or participate in it as as general public members.
Yeah. So there's 2 ways. First way, whenever I engage topic, I'd do so 2
ways. I wanna try to engage with stakeholders within government within DOD, be
able to provide answers to the most pressing questions they have.
Right? Because, again, I'm trying to support national security here at Aviation Safety, and that's
the best way to do it by directly interface to solving the problems that they
have. But we're also engaging the conversation on the civil side as
well. 1 of the activities that we're planning at the
AIaa is actually a small sensor that can be
distributed to schools and the general public, and we're looking to
tie that in with a data provider, a service provider, that would look
to donate that compute time to be able to run algorithms that we're
generating at the AA to provide that wider plethora of
data. It's about trying to find patterns in that data. So the more that we
have, the more we can kinda assess out some of those details. And that's a
similar, I think, process that can be done with eyewitness reports
and non sensor reports. I think the the bar is higher. We need
more data so that we could pull out those trends, but I think
there is valid information to be pulled out of there en masse, right, on average
as we look at the data and How did you react this week and last
week? There's been reports from this Air Force. I guess commander captain
for colonel lieutenant colonel, maybe. I forget. But, anyway,
name, you know, that there's kind of expose that
there have been, you know, claims of of not only alien
craft, but but even alien bodies and so forth. I I
personally find it hard to to accept, and I I don't want you to comment
on him directly. But but this notion that not only do we have to accept
that there are these phenomena, but these phenomena are actually aliens, and these are
actually from distant technology, etcetera. It seems like an insurmountable
barrier to get over. Right? Although, in the past few years, thanks
in some small part to pass guest on the podcast Tom DeLong and
others who have made this know, front page news in New York Times. It
seems like there's an arms race between people that want to believe and people that
want to disbelieve. I was just curious. How did you react? I mean, it's in
your literal space, no pun intended. How did that affect you just as a as
as a citizen and and being someone very active in the space? Yeah.
Great question. You know, it's shocking for me too to hear hear that information
come out. But, you know, I I think of it that I have to remind
people that This didn't naturally come out of nowhere. They didn't actually utilize the
whistleblower protections that were afforded in the 2023 National
Defense authorization act, but it was in response to the NDAA
legislation, which essentially called for what's owed and provided protections.
And so in that language, it very specifically, you know, called out crafted
people programs that use a lot of very impressive language we're not used to seeing
in NDAs. And so, you know, he is someone that
has a lot of experience and has had a lot of access, and he's making
these claims. But like everyone else, this information that he's now
taken before congress, they claim require big evidence. And,
theoretically, they have that evidence in their possession, and now it's in congress's hand to
validate that information. And then share what can be shared, I think, with the
general public. Right, you are. Kinda had a bit
of a discussion the other day just done with the difficulty
of kinda keeping your conspiracy like that. I'm a
bit of a universal skeptics on I I agree big big claims would
require some pretty big data. Mhmm. Obviously, there's credibility
from someone within the intelligence community who had a lot of ties I
reserve judgment till I have I have been able to see more.
Yeah. People say there's a trope that, you know,
eyewitness evidence isn't worth it. You know, they do this thing with a gorilla bouncing
a basketball, and there's a bunch of people. And, oh, they didn't notice the gorilla
came through, and they're counting the number of people. So but but it is a
form of evidence. But the the question and and we briefly touched upon this, but
I think it's valuable to talk about. What constitutes data? Like, when we hear this
word, like, The data belongs to Americans, and this is, you know, this is public
information, and this should be released for the evidence. You ever miss
as lasted once I had on David Chalmers, who's a professor of, you know,
studies of cognitive science and philosophy at New York University.
And I had him on the podcast, and I said, David, you know, he's from
Australia. I said, you know, me not asking you to define the
hard problem of consciousness would be like me. having ACDC from
your homeland of Australia not played back in black. I think, Ryan,
you're back in black. I I would love for you to recount if you were
willing to, what you witnessed because we can talk about crush, and he can talk
about, you know, what he was told by other eyewitnesses. But we have
someone who has had a you know, Ariel had an encounter. He talked about what
that was. It was said, can you would you mind, like, detailing these
these encounters that you I've discussed elsewhere, but I think my audience
is the best in the known universe. So they it I would be remiss if
I didn't ask you to recount back in 5 to 7 years ago, I guess.
Gosh. It's been that long. Uh-huh. 9, actually, no. Yeah. I don't know what it
is. This time this month, it's now been 8 years since I landed on a
boat. Really? Wow. Yeah. We're gonna have to get into the possible aircraft
carrier. Take you guys out office. Yeah. My
experience was we came back from deployment. I got sent to the USS
Enterprise, and you finished a little bit after. I think you joined -- I joined
right after right now. -- we came back. So I joined them on deployment. We
came back. And when we came back, typical happens is you'll start upgrading systems
or repairing things, yadayada. We were upgrading we were a rare lot number,
I think, it's called, where essentially, we were engineered or manufactured so
that we could be upgraded later as a small amount of aircraft that were upgradable
essentially. These are super Super Hornets. Yeah. And so we start upgrading our radars when
we got back, which was awesome because my, like, level 3 check rides can be
so much easier with this radar. That's than what the older ones -- Put out
-- -- have a land more precisely or -- -- precisely. I don't have to
do as much like finger work, you know, and things of that nature. Ops
automation and cockpit resource. But the other a mechanically scanned. It literally
the radar is moving, and you have to if you don't have everything
set properly, it you can actually complete It
required a lot more pilot in the Ohio. Oh, nice. That's demanding
resource. Right? Mhmm. So they had upgraded the block that you Yeah. And it
took a while. It took, I don't know, maybe, like, 3 or 4, 5 months,
possibly, because, you know, it was one at a time, and they take it in
and took, like, a good week to do one aircraft. But, anyways, long story short,
we we're fine with our older radar. We weren't seeing anything really of note,
and then we upgrade our radars and then detecting objects in
our areas. There's two conversations here. Those and that's the one first
conversation I'm having is what my real time experience was. There's some things I've
learned since then -- Mhmm. -- and I'm gonna hold those. But just to be
clear that I'm just kind of talking about my interactions as a
first person observer. Mhmm. And what that was, we we you know, other folks
in the squadron were seeing stuff, and it was you weren't talking about that much
unless it was an incident. We had to move areas or if we went to
look for them. So it's just kinda chatter in the ready room. Eventually, we
started correlating that. We're essentially being on other
sensors. So okay. We were thinking these were radar errors.
know, because you get false track hits on our older radars. At least was my
assumption that this was probably a false track of some type until we start getting
returns at least it's on our camera or our flier system, Keating
flier. At least for me at the time, we was like, okay. Well, if we're
seeing these flier now being correlated, we have to assume these physical objects.
that we have to we have to -- Were there any people saying sorry to
interrupt. Were there any people seeing it on radar as kind of like an experimental
control? Like, was it only on the new radar sets? It's a it's a pretty
big upgrade from 73 to 79. So -- Resolution
power. What what exactly was the up nature of the upgrade to the rim? You
can be as geeky as he wants. sneaky when you carry -- 1 is mechanically
scanned. The other is an -- It's a -- -- constant scanned array.
Power is probably higher. I mean, it's just generally But the same size
ditches or panels or, you know, roughly the same resolution, or would you get, like,
you could see now the tail number? It's probably not limitations to how much
we talk about. Yeah. Yeah. We can't sorry. Sorry out
there. You also deployed Austin. We didn't -- Any conversation never. -- in air to
air, which you probably can't like, air to air, you're just scanning, and it it
just shows you track. It's not not developing a
picture off of the radar. But you said you did see it on FLIR. So
now you've got 2 different wavelengths that are separated by 10 to the
7th order of magnitude, you know, roughly in wavelength. So yeah. So go
ahead. Anecdotally, after the fact and this is, like, later knowledge, I had spoke with
other pilots, interviewed one of my podcasts, I talked with others who
got factored into traffic that was interesting, which placed
stationary objects, and that that's majority of what we were seeing. But he had to
-- Station was ground track? Or how do I go up for me? Okay. Round
track. Yep. Mhmm. And he was asked to go and go
check out the object essentially. This was over by the there. the
range down there. So he went off and and intercepted the ABG 73
radar. He essentially had the quote unquote kinda zoom it in. Mhmm. Zoom in the
radar, but more energy to a smaller piece of the sky in order to break
it up, and they did he did break it up. And as he approached pretty
close, apparently, it it it just started off. and that was that. So I thought
that was interesting because it kinda showed that there was a connection perhaps between kind
of the more resolution or the more radar energy also just on that
spot with, you know, being able to see it better. Mhmm. What was
interesting too we talked about that was there's this thing called the target
aspect indicator, which is, like, you know, that comes off of it. One thing I've
said is that I was identifying these objects by how it works. inconsistent,
the target aspect indicator, and detected these. He said the same thing,
except instead of having it move in consistently, it didn't move at all. when the
object went away from him, it actually went away backwards. So so -- --
use this web's telescope to kinda target aspects. So what would that indicate
if you're tracking web telescope. Yeah. There's a web If we assume this at
the front of it. Right? We're going towards the camera. Yeah. Yeah. There's a
airplane here. Flying along. Yeah. I would expect to
see on my on my radar if we were kinda looking down circle. Oh, yeah.
There we go. So, yeah, if aircraft's going like this in the
wrong direction, then the target aspect basically pointing in the direction the
vehicle is going. Right? And so when I
the target aspect didn't moving it darted away, this was aircraft that had
it, essentially, stationary object, and then it just started flying backwards and flew
away that way. So not to say it actually flew backwards, but the
target indicator never changed direction. I was just if it was kinda
walking backwards out there for pump steps and -- Yeah. More
or less. Yeah. Okay. So we expect that's due to limitations of the
radar that represent the kinematics of the vehicle. Mhmm. So
you saw it on the there's a sensor on the on the missile or whatever.
Or or this is unclear on the jet itself? Okay. So the jet has a
miss and then then then the missiles would have it, but you said you weren't
necessarily armed at that time or or were you? We have our sensors on our
training missiles that we fly with so we can -- Okay. -- get tone on
these objects as it's called, although we can't actually launch on it. know, we would
get tone on them. They would get picked up by the -- Yeah. -- tone
looking at the metallic artist having some radar return. It's giving you some there's a
heat signal. Enough of a heat signature for the missile to to get -- --
track. I'm talking. And the 9 x, if we were carrying the
catam, which is the the fake 9 x, those are those sensors are pretty
resolid. So that's that's like our new
upgrade, the 9 x. Yeah. Right. Those are the ones they shot down the
Chinese balloon with, right, a couple of weeks ago. which we maybe will
get to if we have time, but your thoughts about that. Again, so, yeah, flying
with easy act. I keep going down that. Yeah. So so here we are now.
It's on the FLIR, and then, naturally, people are like, let's go see what they
are. myself included. And, you know, what that looks like is we try to
merge with objects. So here it is, and we typically wanna come below it.
look up on it. We can't see below the aircraft and ideally wanna go
as slow as possible. I like you. No idea. Well, we didn't. Yeah. I mean,
in first time, no. Like, we didn't know, haven't seen it. I don't know how
big it is, really, or -- Yeah. -- it's gonna move or whatever if they're
doing it there, but we would come up to it, and our radar would be
locked on. My I think we and I will be able to change it, but
he knows what my experience. But whatever be locked on, the flier would be on
it, and have a tone. something we trained to a lot, committed mergers. This is,
like, one of the core things that we, you know, trained to. So it's kinda
-- Let's look. And it might help, but it would show me where to look
to see it. I couldn't see anything. So that was
kind of the status quo for a while, you know, at least as far as
I knew at the time where people were trying to fly up to it and
not seeing it. Now I don't know if that means that they didn't all represent
physical objects or if there was other, you know, trickery going on to
prevent a visual ID, but that was status quo for a while
until we had a near midair with one of the objects. So how did that
come down? because and that seems like they have a lot of incentive wanna
avoid that? And, also, could you get in trouble for just going out there, or
could you justify rationalize as part of the training? Like, You're
gonna respect it? Yeah. Just don't plan. Yeah. We certainly have the
agency to go do that at least initially. One of our most
common missions, like, in the Persian Gulf was just seat search. You you go find
any you know, anything you see out there that's you know, you could go and
inspect. You can go and inspect type of thing. And visual con constant
to, like, the highest for because, like, a lot of these could occur at night.
And, by the way, did any of them occur at night? Or -- Yeah. They
were out there at night. Uh-huh. We weren't to my knowledge, and no one was
flying by the men. Right? Uh-huh. a vehicle. So talk about the
near encounter or whatever. Yeah. So it was 2 aircraft
with four people total. Mhmm. Only the first aircraft, the lead aircraft saw
it. they were flying to go do a mission. I don't know what it was
out in the areas. 2 of them flying side by side. They went the way
it works is there's a single point. That's the entrance to the working areas --
Yep. -- at a very particular altitude, and there one leaves a thousand feet below
that or vice versa. But either way, they know, we're tightening up their
formation accelerating. Now they're above 10000 feet. You can accelerate above
253100 knots. Mhmm. And so they're accelerating probably 3.50 closing
in the formation. And then Alleges sees something go over by his
aircraft. And what he described was a dark gray or black cube inside
of a instead of a clear sphere. that was stationary with respect to him,
or -- So -- -- you couldn't tell? No. Yeah. I'm gonna go back a
little bit -- Mhmm. -- because it what I described, it wasn't perfectly accurate. I
said, I've passed them. Right. But that was just a relative Yeah. View. So it's
our understanding that it was stationary at that location, and then that they flew through
it. But, of course, it appeared that way to them. What's their separation? Like, tip
to wing tip. Very tight. I've been using about, you know, 100 to 150
feet as an average because they were probably tightening up to get in there and
stuff. So you don't know the exact distance, but but from there.
Okay. So we still go on. So then they -- Yeah. So the object, you
know, it's hard to, you know, really objectively seek things that they're going by like
that, especially when it's a surprise and all that. So confidence in the data is,
you know, somewhat low here, I'll say. But, you know, he described it. He thought
it came closer to his aircraft, and so he he described it as, like, 5
to 15 feet diameter. that was what he could kinda glean from, you
know, seeing a zip by his aircraft at such close distance if you're hard to
tell the size of objects unless you know what it is. So, yeah, I mean,
that was that was essentially it. He they turned around to cancel the flight after
that. They weren't confident at their you know, or hit or essentially to clear
their nose. They were in the ready room with all their gear on when they
came back. And at this point, we've been seeing and talking about them enough where
he's just like, I don't hate what that was effing thing. We all knew what
he was talking about. Then we were kind of obligated because it was so close
that we had to file a safety report. And kind of the chitchat and the
squadron the commanding officer or whatnot was that, you know okay. It's
Newborn, UFO, UAP. I mean, I didn't know that term UAP. I
don't think it was. I mean, it was a term, but it wasn't somehow a
lower But, you know, we thought perhaps these were some type of classified
program that maybe, you know, had
inadvertently operation where they shouldn't have or whatever, maybe we
could kind of get a message to them that they were now you know, this
was gonna lead to a mishap if they didn't take care of it and get
or, you know, there's stuff in order. And it happened multiple times. Right? There
were multiple sightings of the similar type of variety from
different pilots? Yep. Okay. When we initially filed that safety
report. The part of the conversation was actually like, well, shit. You know, we've been
talking about Steve. I'm sorry. Can I swear out? No. You're a dentist. You too.
Sounds good. It's alright. Sorry. What? My flawless Keating, Moe. Oh, okay.
No. No. People love cursing many times. Alright. Keating like a sailor is another thing.
Oh, yeah. He's trying. What else? Yeah. So,
yeah, multiple people or multiple encounters, Sally, Keating. Is that -- Yeah.
So so what's that called? Well, crap. We've been seeing these things so much. We
can't just have this one taker for it. You know? like, we actually filed several
of them at that same time to kinda show that this wasn't a problem, which
is a you know, that's an error, I think. Right? We shouldn't have taken that
long to report these. But -- Did I just go into the void? I mean,
is this even kinda like blinding? So
I was I was trained by the Navy to be an aviation safety officer. Mhmm.
And there are different reporting mechanisms for different emergencies of the
the hazard that's been identified. you know, potential mid
errors that are of an unknown cause that are you know, have
potential to reoccur. Eventually, that made their way into the notam so that every
time people were flying, there was They went in Montana's to it. It's a notice
to airman. It's something that but -- Don't don't
say it, Ari. -- to sail mission? change it. Yeah. He did change it.
Believe to be inclusive of judges on the case. Alright. He did change it. Yep.
Have learned. So there's a no test. Right? Notice to air missions out. Yeah. So
submitting a ad rep like that, ultimately, it's kinda gonna get mass
blasted out and, like, it's someone's gonna read the email and then file it
away. But that's basically. Yeah. Yeah. We're
gonna have the arc of the covenant. So -- That doesn't have to
support. I mean, maybe it's a blessing in disguise. this might have encouraged you to
start your new mission on the civilian side. Right? I mean, if it was like
the government was taking us very serious, it is disappointing. I have to say as
taxpayer. I don't have the courage that you guys have to, you know, stop me.
I would have liked to, but couldn't fit into the flight suits that you live
with. You guys are pretty diesel. And we I do wanna talk. I always like
to talk with extreme hyper for my audience. I got a lot of young men
out there. They wanna be like you guys, so we'll talk about that at the
end. I wasn't in the jet. You know, you guys are flying on my behalf
and so forth. But, like, This is a lot of freaking, you know, money and
blood treasure potentially going down the drain. I'm kind of pissed off
as a as citizen? You know, what the hell am I paying for, you know,
taxes for? If you they're not gonna be protected. How much money goes into a
training enable aviator and a high performance aircraft? Midlions.
Right? It's got Somewhere to 15,000,000 to access to
level 3, probably. Yeah. Yeah. So millions of And and that's trivial
compared to the cost of losing a single person. Right? It's quite frankly
a shame that that you know? And this is multiple government presidential
administration. You can't blame it on the current one. Right? I'm disappointed as a
taxpayer. Right? I'm assuming too. I didn't realize it was still a problem
until 2017, the New York Times article came out.
And I recognized the video or the image that was on that because that was
taken by a squadron made in mind. And I was like -- That's a so
called gimbal. Yeah. That's a holy smokes. This is this is this is not
being resolved whatsoever. There's still an issue. And so I reached back to somebody and
just asked you know, what was going on and even still an issue. And
and that's kinda that's that's that was my decision. At this point, I hadn't even
really thought of it. frankly, I hadn't thought of it after I left until I
saw that. And then I was like, holy smokes. This is this is not gonna
get resolved -- Mhmm. -- within the normal systems. And that's kinda what led me
down the path of all today. I mean, it's it would be disappointing, and, I
mean, you could comment on the story. But, you know, that's the only way to
get attention to things that could be extremely dangerous, but prosaic.
In other words, it could be, you know, drone or whatever. It could be less
prosaic, like Alien Technology or somewhere in between, like, a
military, obviously. the only way to get attention is to whistle blow. It seems like
a broken system. Inside of that or someone crashes into it, and then they
investigate, and then it'll become an issue. But -- That's why we have the safety
Right. -- actively look at what the problem was. Right? So that's that's how we
do it. We write our procedures in blood. You still think that they're out there
now or whatever these objects were or still being claimed to be cited. Mhmm.
And what about the commercial traffic? Okay. So it's a warning area. So it's not,
like, likely the southwest is gonna be operating and then necessarily It
could. I mean, the warning areas can be inactive, and then IV traffic
can get routed through it. Mhmm. So so we have questions from the audience, and
please leave a couple questions. We're gonna for a little bit longer, then we're gonna
go have a nice ship. But we're gonna introduce Ryan to Shabbat if he
hasn't had it already. Did you you tell him about the brisk meal of the
circus no. You didn't tell know. We'll talk about that later. Okay. Don't worry about
that. Can Ryan go into Malik's, the Gimbal analysis? I don't know.
Leak is, but what about the Gimbal if you if you're comfortable with it? And
what what is a Gimbal? What does it have to do with this event, and
what are some explanations both, you know, on both kind of sides of the fence?
So the term Gimbal was given to a video that was released by
navy The name of the video has no consequence to anything
objective. It's just someone in the navy apparently gave it that name. I
was really actually kinda curious too. probably a good question. So, you know, let's
not over index on that particular name. But, you know, a
Gimbal is an object typically is spend in a self, you know, self cracks and
stabilizes itself based off of the centrifuge. I
know there's one that's always the wrong one. Right? That's right. Richard Feiman said, if
you know the difference, you're a high school physics teacher.
That's right. Only high school physics teacher. So it's yeah. It's
a platform that's gyro stabilized gyroscopically. Same things for pointing platforms.
They're all over the place, and technology usually hit it. But this object
that appeared in the video appeared appeared
to almost act like a gimbal because it it seemed to be, you
know, wider in the middle, I guess. And, yeah, I don't know the justification,
frankly. Right? So I'm not even gonna try to explain, you know, and and name
it. But you can't get the sense. Oh, this kinda looks like a gimbal. that's
moving around in strange ways. And the story behind that is we were
out off the coast of Jacksonville, Florida. We were doing our I believe it
was just a workup event, which is No, sir.
Yeah. Jesus. It's the so hard questions on the
intended When you go through 2 workups before getting deployed
certified to go deploy. The first is Tista. So that's just you
as an air wing operating with carrier, then you go through comp 2 x, which
is you as a battle group operating together. So it's just -- We're a comp
2 x x. Okay. No. Okay. Uh-huh. that's more a little more tactical.
So, yeah, great great question. I cannot
remember what the acronym stands for them. -- for you. Alright. So, anyways, we were
out there, and that's what we do. We're operating off the aircraft carrier. We're doing
training. And, honestly, it's more dangerous and more intense than combat operations.
at least our modern operations. So it's it's pretty intense. They they they do push
us and stretch our, you know, capabilities -- Mhmm. -- and it's graded
as well. But, anyways, one day we're gonna do an air to air flight. We
go out together, do the mission, and then as you come back 1 by 1,
as you run out of fuel, you you don't just go back to a boat
and land you slow down to a non tactical airspeed, a max
endurance airspeed, and you basically get out of the way and just go hang out.
And you just hit we call it hang out in the blades. waiting for the
landing to open up at the boat, but we don't have enough fuel to just
bring it up and go fly tackle. So we have no choice, but to just
hang wait more. Mhmm. Lordering for your landing spot. Right? Like, I got a gate.
Give the gate to open up for a civilian -- Mhmm.
So it was during this time that this aircraft came back. They
detected a number of objects on their radar notice that on their situational
awareness page. they noticed it to the east of the carrier. Additionally, they thought that
it was perhaps some type of penetration test because during this, they actually send
out where their aircraft or simulated fighters from the
shore to test a carrier's reaction, essentially. And so if we're
doing some mission, you know, you might be task with knocking it off, you meant
to go a training mission, knock it off to go go see these guys essentially.
I'm trying to intercept them. So that's essentially what they did. They saw these they
thought perhaps that's what it was. It was strange because they're in the east of
the boat. We're already a few hundred miles out coast. So, you know, these kefirs
and whatnot that fly, it's I don't know how they would have got out there
without a scene then. So that's the red red square or red what'd you call
it? Red. Red. Red. Red. Yep. There's an after series that are paid to commercial
or, you know, civilian aircraft even sometimes. Right? Yeah. Yeah. And so
they went to essentially inspect these objects. They called
Morles Stern converted it, which essentially they approached it and tried to get behind it
and started flying up to it. Initially, you know, my memory served. It was somewhere
in the 6th day nautical mile that they had got with in this object. I
actually later had the pilot. It came up to my house to hang out. We're
still friends. You know, when I asked, I was like, crack my memory. How close
were you guys? You know? And he's like, dude, we do four to six miles.
You know? So even close than I originally thought. Mhmm. They got about four to
six miles from it. It was dark and, you know, My understanding is they peeled
off at that point and headed back to the boat. And so that was the
gimbal object you see there. There were other objects as well. I learned about
this when I watched the debrief in the in the civic space, what they
played their tapes. And there was 4 to 6 objects.
I call them smaller objects. Mhmm. 4 to 6 smaller objects that were kind of
past the gimbal object that we're flying in a formation. And their
target aspect indicator resembled the scattering that
the One's at the east coast we're displaying. So for
me, that led me to assume that they were perhaps the same objects that
we had seen, but they don't necessarily have evidence of that. Mhmm. The gimbal object,
we had never seen anything like that before. That was unique.
So a question from the audience here from somebody named
4 get it 25, which I was gonna name my 3rd child 4
get it. What kind of reduction in speed or need for thrust would going against
the wind characteristics? look like a la the Gimbal video. In other
words, what kind of let's say it was a you know, just to whatever, drone
or what have you. stexicopter, as I like to say.
What would it be, you know, what would it require? It's like hurricane force, you
know, stability or, you know, could how how could you stabilize it?
What kind of velocities, relative velocities, and so forth were involved?
I'm not a 100% sure. I understand the question. I think you're saying we would
assume it was a standard drone. You know? Well, presumably, there's some
altitude wind in there. How how how you're a 100 miles to think is
what they were -- So you Yeah. I see it needs substantial thrusting. So they're
asking, yeah, stabilize it in the wind. So it's stable with respect to a ground
track. It would need to have exactly the negative of that velocity. You'd have to
know how big the aircraft is. Like, there are a lot of different factors. It
wasn't stationary, though. Yeah. But the ones earlier oh, so the get the get what
was that stationary? Correct. against the the backdrop. Yeah. So that's why I understand. But
yeah. So it actually wasn't stationed there. Uh-huh. It's turn a r movement. It was
going against the wind, which was north of a 120 knots. And so to the
original question, which is what I think about that thing. Essentially, what was
done, I think there was, like, some open source work that was done by Midwest
and others that created a model for the kinematics of the Gimbal
and the net that were derived from what can be seen in the FLIR
display itself. That model, the only variable, essentially,
that's an unknown is the distance from the jet to the
unknown object. Mhmm. If you use witness data
to fix that object at about 4 to 6 miles
away from the aircraft, then the
kinematics and trajectory of the aircraft essentially look like a j hook word.
So this is vertical right here. Someone Keating and is climbing and essentially doing a
j hook. if you take that model and you extend that out to thirty miles
or so, it's a straight and level trajectory flight profile.
And so if you the most logical assumption that people make if
they don't include the pilot
testimony is that that's really the most logical path for it to be, the straight
and level path at all our distance. If you include the
pilot testimony, what you arrive at is that J Hook maneuver,
which is interesting because that is essentially what was seen on the situational
awareness page where the object was proceeding in one direction and this is a god's
eye view that we see on this. So the object appeared to just stop and
go back in the other direction. But it -- Why, man? -- it could have
just done a very tight turn -- Mhmm. -- that that model represents. So the
model's interesting because, again, it was kind of an open source effort. It wasn't one
particular person. It's just whether you want to include that testimony. That's my
understanding of it. You know, I haven't delved into the model that much. But
yeah. You know, getting back to this notion of military organizations
And by the way, it's not just navy. It's air all the services, maybe even
the Space Force, you know, dealing with these phenomena in some way or another NASA
is as well. We mentioned David Spurgle. Keating on Simon's Observatory's
President of Simon's Foundation. He's leading NASA panel. My colleague, Shelley
Wright, professor Shelley Wright here. He's of an optical Keating looking for extraterrestrial
intelligence using laser signals for receiving laser
signals from a potential extraterrestrial civilization.
that you guys are both out of the out of the service. But it just
seems kinda callous. It seems like they are not taking this
seriously, and and I guess the question is, would you advise a young, you
know, Brian, you know, go back in time, like, go back into the military, Ari,
what let's start with you, Ari. Would you say, like, you know, an organization that's
treating its employees in this in this sense just from a, you know, a business,
you know, recruiting perspective, HR perspective, on LinkedIn, Here's this
entity. We we we routinely have events that could cause
your untimely demise, and we invite you to submit an
email on this forum on SurveyMonkey. and that's about it. Would you advise a
younger Ari to go into the navy or any military service? Let's say the Air
Force, those guys, you know. They're not would you advise them? there's a
I have a lot of gripes with certain things within the military. That
being said, though, I mean, I got one of the most unique experiences. I think
it developed me in Yeah. I was
a nerdy kid growing up in Princeton from academic
family, Ivory Tower. You know, I've traveled a lot, but it gave
me a different a very different worldview and perspective and confident
and the military paid me to fly $80,000,000
jets. Yep. you know, you have to taper, like, military lifestyles
stuff. There's a lot of time away, deployments. I do think they
frequently you know, I think we are burning our force, and that's that's
something that I it it that's a larger question. But, you know, I think we're
we're burning our people. And a lot of people are leaving the military.
Lifestyle is extremely hard. We're we're operating at wartime
conditions for 2020, 20 plus years. And it doesn't seem to
let off, and and I think that is impacting our force. And I feel for
you know, especially the the maintainers and the sailors that they're it's an
extremely hard we're we're requiring a lot of people.
Conversely, like, it is extremely unique and amazing
experience, though. They do not No women. So I I would caution. I'd I'd
tell anyone, you know, if my kid, my son wanted to become a a fighter
pilot, I'd tell him, hey. Like, you know, are you willing to do
x, y, z? Are you willing to get you know, have to deal with these
things? I wouldn't tell them not do it. I would but I I just thought
I'd give them the pros and cons, and then, you know, I think there's I
think they're both. So Well, you're right. I think when you do that
job, you accept a lot of risk. I'm not gonna give you the whole point
to check the payment. But but what we do at aid dealers is we
we mitigate risk, and we and therefore, we accept it.
and that's fine. And that's, you know, what we sign up to do. And
occasionally, however, you run-in the scenarios that can be rare
where you are introduced to risk that has no mitigation.
Mhmm. And that I think is a disservice. And that's what we
started with in this conversation. I've seen it other times in the military,
and it hasn't ended well. But we have to be communicate
those risk appropriately. And I think we're starting to do that with the
reporting process that are going in place. So to the wider question, you know, I
would again probably communicate with my child very clearly on the
risk that they would be accepting by doing that. And I just hope to God
to make a good decision. Right. because I don't wanna tell them what to do,
but I wanna you know, do my best to give them a wide view of
all the options. Mhmm. Okay. Chris French 83 on Twitter is
asking a question for Ryan. Please, Ryan. So far, do you have any pilots who
reported to you seeing the same metallic spheres in the skies around the world?
Commercial pilots, military, etcetera? Are we being is it the uniquely
American phenomena or -- Yeah. I'll answer this differently, which
is I'm not saying this, but doctor Shankar Patrick and even in the
last NASA infested IT and public meeting stated that these were being
seen in all operational areas around the world. Mhmm. k. Pete
Venkman asking the sphere and cube matches the description of radar
reflectors. Makes these objects spotted by Graves And
Company anomalous not simply a radar reflection or similar object.
Yeah. So, you know, I've had this conversation many times, but
here's here's the here's the problem. I describe various situations
of these these objects, and they're stationary or they're doing x or they're doing
y. Where things get more anomalous is when you kinda zoom out
You zoom out and you look at the object temporarily over time, and you say,
okay. It was tank stationary, and then it was, you know, it
was Keating at very high speeds in a holding pattern for a very long period
of time. That that becomes hard to explain. And
it's the accumulation of all those data points over time that kinda leads us into
the well, we don't actually know what it is. Fuck it. It doesn't lead us
into a conclusion, but it it crossing certain things out and just leaving us
with that question mark over our head still. Scott and
debunked. Scottish debunked 1 for me. Sorry to bother. Can you
ask on certain vector? By the way, follow what we're saying on on Twitter, on
certain vector, and follow the merch podcast as well as we'll get into
that and a bit. What is the relationship other than being 10 minutes apart between
Gofast and Gimble video? Talk to you about Gimble. Talk about Gofast.
Yeah. What is the relationship? Well, I'd like to I'll once again
suggest that we were not responsible for the naming of that deal.
But Yeah. This is when I actually don't have a
lot of data on, when I went into the room to wash those tapes
after they landed, that's not a video that I watched or
saw. Okay. I've spoken with the pilot since then, and they
have some they have some questions about that video as well. So -- Okay.
Brodag, which is not my brother-in-law, brodag, out there in my
marine car, recon hurrah, and a gentleman listening
out there. I love it, brother. Has Ryan contacted Senate sub committee for
aviation safety operations and innovation to raise awareness of the UAP
issue from an aviator's perspective. If not, I kindly suggest for him in safe
aerospace. to engage with the Senate sub committee chaired by Senator
Duckworth. It's only a great idea. We're engaged through American's for
safe aerospace with congressional oversight committee. as well as the
national security subcommittee. But the one that was just mentioned is not
one we're engaged. We're also looking at this FAA reauthorization that's
occurring this year. Is there room in there for any type of
UAP budget at the FAA, considering how they were just Keating, how they're having such
a hard probably, you know, have a they didn't have the resources or the tools
to actually be able to to track or or potentially investigate these occurrences.
Question from Gaston Pierre. Keating out must have drastically
influenced his daily life. His world view is friendships, and I'm I
assume they're talking about you, not me. My favorite subject. His
worldview is family, his family life, relations as military brothers. Can he
tell a bit about the time frame in which the most intense changes took place
for you. I I don't know if you're comfortable asking it, but answering it. That's
a big one. I think it's a good one. It's a it's kinda meta Licks
Friedman style, Keating of life and love, etcetera. you feel comfortable with that?
How did it affect you as a human? As a man, as a father, as
a husband, if at all? Yeah. You know, it's one of those things where
it's it's a conversation that was a slow
boil for me at least personally. I can't speak for everyone.
Mhmm. And so I feel like I'm very much inside
of the conversation still. In a way, like, we there's no conclusion here that I've
reached. You know? We have a lot of work to do. And so In a
way, I'm I'm not even in a position to kinda retroactively look back and, you
know, assess that because I still feel like I'm in that slow boil.
But there has been a lot of changes. I mean, you know, I wasn't expecting
to engage in the subject, of course. I wasn't expecting
to speak on, you know, news. That was that was all stuff that was
outside the scope of my experience. I know if I'm doing a good job of
this question, but I don't know. I think they'll want you to go a little
personal. I mean, you are the steely eyed kinda guy and you get this, you
know, whatever. You guys both of you You guys have this this persona. And
I I I respect you tremendously, and and I have great fondness for
you. And if my sons or daughters wanted to do what you guys do, I'd
be I'd be I point them to you for Sage advice, but I know I've
seen things or whatever and and and had experiences. None of
which are potentially at the level of this, but I mean, you know, if
you're religious, it could be America. I mean, when you encounter something like
that, it has to affect you as a as a man. I guess,
Yeah. I guess that's an issue of the question. I'm curious too. I'm glad gas
can ask it so I can phrase my my, you know, comment in the
form of his question. But you know, to what extent does I mean, the
implications of what you you're involved with are both
from Keating lives, protecting individuals, and securing
our country. But even beyond that, you you have to realize that these are these
are huge implications. How can that not change a human being on a personal level?
I think that's what the I've tried not to let it change me to the
point. We talked to us a little bit earlier, right, where we have a line
of objective data and inclusions and extrapolation on the other
side of it. You know? I've I've I've tried
to not let things to this point affect me because I truly you
know, I at my 4, I need more data to be able to make a
conclusion about this. I'm not driven with the conclusion in mind.
So so for me personally, have tried not to let you I'm sure absolutely
it has. Right? I'm not I'm not trying to be facetious with, but She doesn't
have your wife. It's not like I yeah. Exactly. Yeah. So we get her on
the podcast. But, you know, I never feel like I had this big come to
you this moment where my light my worldview changed. I feel like I'm I'm
I'm hesitant to engage in that type of self reflection because there's
just so much other work to do before we can get there. Mhmm. Not the
answer. I know people wanna hear, but -- I know. Okay. -- that's how I've
tried to you know There are a lot of I think, I mean,
as a product, you have a lot of
instances in your career that, yeah, are gonna fit change you
to, you know -- Mhmm. -- from scaring scaring yourself to
death multiple different times throughout your course where you're, you know, a second away
from going into the ground or land just, you know, landing
on a pitching deck at night and having to go around four times because the
conditions are terrible and Yeah. There are a lot of things that,
you know, shape you. So -- Next comment comes from
the listeners. Name, I'll tell you in a second. Right. I'm just asking why am
I so hot? It's very strange. Generic Gay guy is the
name. Brian, why are you so hot? So what made you shave your
head? Wait. My mama made me, I guess. Yes. Good end. I assume
they're asking about it. Oh, yeah. He is available. He is available,
ladies out there to submit. I'm his I'm his
agent. I wanna I wanna address the shaving. Head question
first before we move on. Yeah. At least -- -- my head probably every few
years for a while. I used to do in the navy a little bit. But
The difference, I think, this time is that I'm continuing to shave it. So, you
know, I'll let that speak for itself. On my
friend's past guest, Brett Weinstein and others have said, you should
assume it's a sign up. Let's dig into that just for fun
speculation. What is the purpose of a Saip? We hear that all the time. Saip.
So what does it mean? First of all, I think it means, and you guys
correct me if I'm wrong, you know, that it's it's it's something done by some
forced to undermine and separate and atomize the
coherence integrity and so forth of another of another entity
of an adversary. Yeah. I'd like to think you know, there's almost no better
way you could engineer the atomization, the polarization of
an already fragmented country you know, start introducing things that just
completely bizarre. We can't explain them. We don't understand them. They could be
military. They could be adversaries. to what level, you know, should do you
agree with the statement made by Brett, you know, assume it's a sign up unless
proven otherwise? And what scenarios could you envision a sign up
playing out? Like, what would be the motivation? Who would be behind it? Let me
start with you on that. And then as a sign
up itself. I mean, People have been experiencing
phenomenon in in aviation. I I haven't. But, you know, like, even
you hear about early astronauts seeing things in outer space
that they couldn't you know? So the the fact that there there are things that
need to be looking into, I don't think, would be that aspect. I know the
SIOP I've heard a little bit. I think I read some articles
a couple of years ago. That, I think, goes more onto them trying to
create a external threat that would impose the 1 world
government as sort of the generally, the the situation that I've heard that
as -- Wait a minute. Yes. Saab could also be something within, say, the
navy. Right. It could be We wanna test the loyalty of Ryan or this
whistleblower. Someone in the air force is concerned. I'm just making this up, by the
way, it precautions out there. But, you know, they wanna test. They have some suspicions.
Maybe he these leaked information about what or whatever. Again, preface it. I'm
not accusing him. I'm just saying, There could be it could be within it doesn't
have to be China. Right? It could be something they're trying to smoke out something,
suss out something. That could be a motivation that's not a even a foreign entity
and and to or it could be stress testing. We do these SWAT analyses
on telescopes and how resilient are to a virus that
takes down, you know, our supply chains to Chile, why not a SIOP?
So I think I think the first thing said is the fact that it would
be entirely legal for that to happen. For us to target Ciox on,
you know, US citizens would be
highly, highly legal, and I think would likely irreparably
damage its trust between the federal government and its citizens as
it as you should. frankly, if that was the case.
So, you know, it sounds like perhaps this question is more directed towards the
recent statements made by Gruss and his activities. So
yeah. I mean, to the point, yes. Sure. Assume it's a sign up. And even
if he's not involved, right, he could be receiving data from
ten people, and all ten of those people are, you know, part of the
SIOP and are fighting it with bad information. And so to that point, let's wait
and see what type of evidence is presented to congress and, you know, a lot
of them to vet that information. because, ultimately, that's the only thing that's gonna sway
anyone's mind. So we're just gonna continue the process. process has been
established. So, like, think there is a way to do this now. So whether you
think it's a sign up or not, let's just let this play out. Now
you're the secretary of defense, and I made you. I just promoted you. I'll ask
you this in. Actually, again, you're the president. Yeah. That's
and president Kidding. Keating up. So
yes. Now you have all these resources at your disposal. You
could commission astronomers around the world to all train their
telescopes. All the what what's on your dream list to
increase the data content? quantity,
quality, precision, calibration, what sorts of things could
my colleagues in astronomy do? I criticize Avi when he came in the
podcast. Like, he has a vested interest and and some of the stuff he's doing.
But, you know, it is true. There were no civilian, you know, efforts to look
at the sky. But now let's take it. Let's just say, by fiat, You were
-- Lloyd Austin or whatever. Mhmm. What would you do? What what kind of
supplementary information data, etcetera, quality, quantity, calibration?
Would you would be most beneficial to you and your mission?
So I I'm not gonna answer the way you want, but we can go into
some of that more after. But to start, I would say, sadly,
it's not a technological problem. It's a stigma problem. And
so if I was, you know, in that position, I would be pushing in the
middle management ranks in order to standardize reporting on this across all
the services. I think they're buying at the top. They're buying from operators,
but there's, you know, essentially, middle
rank officers that are, you know, at that operational level that
either gonna make or break that system. And if they don't have buying on it,
there's also ways that you can implement that into training into the actual
AV and training pipeline, things of that nature. So
Keating a reduction of that will increase pilot reporting to enable
new data. that will allow this conversation to be a normal
scientific endeavor, you know, in our capitalistic market. We can have, you know,
an industry around this. We can advanced sensors. We can potentially get
government funding for these different companies to be able to expand and
provide solutions to the government. So reducing stigma, I think, just
allows this whole conversation to open up. But then when you start looking you
know, now to more directly answer your question, I think there are some, you know,
there's some signatures that have been spoken about by Doctor Shankar Patrick that
are potential targets of opportunity in the
1 to 3 gigahertz range, and I've got the the higher range but there's some
other things that we're doing looking at such as what are some perhaps
passive detection capabilities that we could utilize. And so think there's some
very interesting ways we can leverage existing transmit
technologies, I'll say, very loosely, to be able to passively
identify services and electromagnetic radiation, things of that
nature. And so being able to look at passive systems, I think, are
huge, and there's a a number of options all the way I won't get
into the details. But there's a number of passive systems that could be used. And
then, of course, on the active side, I think, anywhere from wideband
hyperspectral base centers from space, are an ideal,
you know, kind of low hanging fruit that could be attacked. And then, you
know, more fun conversation is one of the coolest things you could potentially
do with gravity detection, things of that nature. Are we able to
specifically adjust our radar systems so that we can
more predictably see these things. Can we then take that data and
combine it all and and and apply machine learning to it so we can perhaps
get proactive detection of these objects to be able to cue our sensors one
of the big problems I believe is gonna be latency due to the load of
high velocities that we're seeing in the the the low amount of time
that these occurrences happen over -- Mhmm. -- that if we do wanna have follow-up
investigation, we're gonna have to have probably some predictive analysis
or predictive capability in North QR sensors. And so advanced
algorithms, more data, anything that's going to be able to increase some
out of data through sensors is going to ultimately add to the conversation. So
Yeah. We're down to the benefit and safety of aviation
space in America and beyond. And we can get we can get data from that
too if we're able to proactively interrogate and -- SKU and
that. Right? Then we can start being, you know, more intelligent. We can start being
more defined with what we're actually looking for instead of being reactionary. And
for dick, than just so you know, it's like they're I always call it the
the ring doorbell fallacy. You know? You buy these ring doorbell monitors. They allow you
to see who stole your package. You know? And, like, What time exact? Times
stand to the micros say, alright. What about you as we wrap up today's conversation?
What what kind of if you were, you know, god, more of a god, a
handsome spider punch. We're gonna step it in.
Yeah. We have rags here. Okay. Alright. I don't wanna the rank card. So
what would you do? I mean, as a scientist, as a physicist, trained physicist, strong
astrophys, what would you wanna do to increase not not all. Ryan
covered the benefits to, you know, to aviation safety and and
so on. What would you do just as a speculative, maybe, wild
speculation? What would you most wanna do? figure out how to get myself a ride
into space. Yeah. That's the day,
Jeff. No. I think, you know, just, yeah,
funneling money to people like Ryan or others and, you
know, haven't given it much thought, so I can't can't go too far
into that. Gentlemen, as we finish up. Well, first of all, I
wanna ask you to talk a little bit about the Merge podcast. How has it
affected you, again, in the in the bright lights and big big
microphones of being a podcast or what what are you getting out of it? What
does it do for you? What do you like about it? I I am learning
how much I say filler words. I'm realizing
how Pop Gun didn't tell you that. Wow. My Keating is even, yeah, even
more so, and how much I don't like listening to my own voice.
Yeah. Very common, but What I am what I am experiencing
that's positive is that we're able to widen this conversation in a
way that is bringing more people into it in a way that couldn't be
done either way, frankly. And who's your dream guest besides the 2 of us? Who's
your dream guest on the podcast? He's active duty right now, so I
can't say his name. Okay. If you could talk to
president by Moji or Dirk vice president Harris because she seems to be
in charge of, like, artificial intelligence, which we didn't get into, Hopefully, when you come
back or I come out to New Hampshire, right, we'll do a part 2, that'd
be great. If you could talk to the highest levels of World Government, what would
you tell them? I would just make it clear how pragmatic this issue is
and how commonplace it is that this isn't necessarily a historical
conversation that happened a long time ago, and we're looking to add to that
context now. It's something that is pragmatic and has potentially real
consequences from not only national security, but aviation safety.
If we look to Eastern Europe, we need to know who's who in the zoo
there, and we don't wanna have unknown third party objects that are potentially causing
misfire things of that nature. So just let them know that you're very serious
national security issues and is a pertinent and urgent problem.
Okay. So Ariel knows this because he was on the last time with a
major he's a major. A hazard league. I found an episode up here down there
wherever you want. I would like to ask 1 or 2 existential questions.
I saw how deep you like to go, you know, on the interpersonal things. That's
that's that's fine. But I do wanna ask you, The name of this podcast called
Into the Impossible, and it comes from sir Arthur C Clarks, one of his many
victims. He has many of these aphorisms. One is any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable from magic. But another one is
the only way of determining the limits of the possible is to go beyond
them venture into the impossible. So I'm gonna ask you
in the form of advice to your former self, twenty year old Ryan. I'm not
necessarily anything to do with what you're doing. What advice would you give
him to do as you've done to give him the courage to go into the
impossible? Yeah. I was just told him to be bold and fearless.
Ultimately, what held me back, I think, and held a lot of pullback is just
fear of acceptance. And if you're always driving yourself towards a mean,
that's where you're gonna end up Fantastic. Ari,
any questions for you, buddy? Thank you for coming back on the
show. I hope to have you at many times. You're a fan favorite. People follow
Ryan on Twitter on certain vector. We love vector calculus
around here, don't we? And as merch podcast, you find that on YouTube. I don't
know audio channels. Got some great interviews and some ones coming up you
told me about in the can, and you'll have to subscribe to find out about
that. And I really wanna thank you, and I wanna thank both of you guys.
You guys are are heroes of mine. You're the best of what America has to
offer. And I really do salute your courage and and learn everything.
You know? You and I get together a lot, and that's great. And I learned
a lot from you today, and I hope we'll be able to do a part
2 sometime. So for now, we're gonna go out and have some some sweet kosher
wine. Everybody out there, Chabacha and lemon, if you celebrate. If not,
happy 4th July. We'll see you guys for a little while. Thank you for
your service as well, and it's been a blast. Thanks, guys. Yeah. Let's
go have some hala.